お願いします
2011年
3月11日
私たちは今までに経験したことのない大震災に見舞われました
地響き激しい揺れそして悪夢のような黒い津波
爆発しないはずの原発の大爆発
東日本大震災
この日の出来事が無情にも私たちの思いで心そして命を跡形もなくサラっていきました
3年が経ち鮮明だったあの日の記憶がみんなの中で薄れ始めている今でもあの日傷を
負った人々の時間は今も止まったまま
動いていません
この映画は止まった時間を少しでも動かしたいという願いであり東北と日本をつなぐ
希望の駆け足であり皆さんへの招待状です
今言葉は
俺の娘です
学院
16歳 hiro 当社時に抱きながら
だから録音しました
せて党運営すると生チョコ白砂に都合でした
私の友達こういう外すと早くを配布し
行きました
ドコモ勢が作ったことなかったんですけど
被災地の皆さんの本年と声をぜひ世界串たちに伝えたいと思って撮りました
自分の妹私の祖母叔母の手を握って
で僕は津波を見てママを見て津波を見てワンツーと以外でも津波があのヒットしてき
ました
それでそれで僕のあのあの家族の物語はもう終わってしまったんですね
死んでしまいましたうん
基礎を残して全部なくなった思い出もノンババアまま子供おじいちゃんおばあちゃん
焼けて死んでたわけですね
あたりを
このしてくれればそこに向かってみんなで頑張るんですよ
明かりがないんです復興は非常に難しいインパし風呂だと思っています
私の知ってる人だけの2人もずここ2カ月で2人自殺してるんです
石巻市がね今ね1か月
10人自殺しているんですだから3日に1人ずつ自殺してるんです
生きるためには隣の人と話して挨拶をするようになった街を歩くと
と4月なんかは
誰とでもあいさつするような素晴らしい管球目でしたあ僕はあの一人の一人の平凡な
人間ですからね
じゃあどうするかというと毎朝の勇気と希望をもってあのを切ることにしています
それから
映画を
影響力は分かってどんどんと僕の話を取るよう太い今日と思って
次の映画
この君のたくましい調整等
偶然出会ったんだけど本柱が運命的予定でした
変なものを作ってしまったねー
人間はな大地の中にこういう村しておけばよかったものを
ビジネスてしまったとき
爆発した後
にそれが郡山にアップ来たんですね
そのにするみたいにはどんどんが白く雪な強敵を過ぎて
もう福島音割だと思う機でなるいらないと言いますか
一番悔しいのはいい
私3種には福島で事故が起きると思っていなかったんです
nan じぇい
今回みたいな事があったら栗なわけでしょ
本当に健康な野菜は作れなくなっちゃったり
そしてちょうど福島に生まれているだけなのにそういう
なっても自業自得だとかそういう交付機も載ってるからそんなこと言えないだろうとか
言われること自体はホント腹たちもての原発を作ってきたのは男たちです
お金が大事だという男たち一番大事なのはやっぱり命であり健康であり子どもたちが
すくすくと育つ育つことだからほとんどの人は胸の中に不安を持ってるんですよ
健康被害が出るかもしれないこれは食べられないかもしれない
元になるかもしれない
電力会社の社長自ら原子炉の側に住め
原発の敷地内に家を建てて住んでみろ
子供とか孫を連れて
福島が映画超えたいな被爆制作思うんです
この次の映画はま
境界杭のかな
を壊してやり方があったんですけど
とにかくないといけないよええ
そういう疑問を感じています
もうなんて静かなんだけってん
やっぱり夜になった何濃度もね理由
誰でもなっても人もいないか車はしてないよ
出てまぁ犬ね御あの頃おいで茎になんなかったもんなぁ
ただもうみんな生え下がってだぺろ
原発から約45キロ離れています
孫は必ずあの保育園に行くと理事ここに来て牛をざっと一回りして食べから保育園に
行くんだよ
家が好きで好きでああ
まだ親子で生きてだ牛がいたわけでも
もうどっちもガリガリだってからもう水前さんをもう1巻が出まくってるんだから
ね校舎やっぱりおっぱい吸いたくて親の後2軍だよな
おっぱいもう少しっていう時に親はもう
おっぱい出るのはがってから儲けるんだを講習
それでもまだをおっぱい欲しくてまで行くわけよ
まだ蹴られる理由もうまだ行くわけでこれでも
でも3回キャッチャーも講師も考えたんだなもう行ってもダメだ
ん
なに考えたか知らないけれども後ろへの過度にロープが下がっ
ロープの下がっているそのしたがもう乳首に見えたんだからすごいって乳首
チャカチャカピカチュウって吸ってたんだよ
いやそれ見たらもうもそこを見て何かあったもん
一番言い思えでね
あまりないなも
いくら悲しいことがあっても目の前に自分の感覚がなくなっても金庫
続けて切るしかないんです
次は福島でいきのホテル日立
話していた
暗いトンネルに入り込んじゃったような状況だったんですけども
このお店は
その希望の光になるといいなぁと思ってます
原発の年と去年はね
車運転してて周りを見るでしょ
景色を見るでしょう福島の山とか
空とか畑とか
そうするとねー
涙が出てきてしょうがなかったんですこんなに綺麗なのにみんな放射能で汚染されたん
だと思うと私ほんと白地キュート
クルマに乗るたびに涙を流してたんです
でも3年目になったら
こんな風に変わってきたの汚染されててもここは私の大好きな場所だ
そう思うと涙出ないんですよ
立ち上がって一緒にいればこちらがらがいいと思います
毎年11月11日に石巻に行って同じ一字インタビューして映画を作っているんです
けど3回ウェイはもうよくなくよくなっているかなーと思ったんですけどやっぱり実際
話は違いますね
あるけどどこが出ちゃったんだろうねぇ
記述ん
何ともどこに彼にちゃったっぽい心に病考えるわけですよ
そういう著書が takumar ほとんどの方がそういう状態になってるわけですよ
やっぱり2年8カ月も経過してね
あの石巻市ではもう非常に厳しい局面を迎えてきている
確かに見ると悲しい辛いことですけれども僕はでもやっぱり残すべきだと思います
なぜか人はね忘れやすいからなんですよ
忘れ去られつつあるのだねもう過去のことに沿い
我々はまだなろう
ねその東日本大震災はまだ続いてるんですよね
あん時は純粋だったんですよ
と思いも人災9形でまだ続いているという
残さ田監督通ってるところで白をナビました
私だけど東北の地へ
一人でもなくなったら悲劇のところ
石巻のお母さん
スーパームーン避難して便前に中近所友達がへ流れていくことを言いました
手を飛ばして止めようとしたんだけど伊豆学習すぎると止められなかったんですね
それでその3日コーヒー数坂おいて
その日に決まったんですけどなくなって友だちと近所の人たちのかわいいリング自分が
一生懸命生きることにしました
文京14
空気は
つよいぞみんな元気になるんですけど
新作には非常に重要です
石巻の方では
9人が医師たちが自分 a からデー
彼車から探して鉄塔特に数を飲んだりん
関税も食べたりして
君県強いところは区民消しもできうち
物資に届くし
全然違いますこれがまた東京の色ところの日本震災たわけですが
組み手を強くしましょう
もう隠さ
数えられないほど素晴らしい一となりました
自分たちの人生をを捨てるぐらいの勢いね
朝から晩まで弱い一の瞬間に頑張ってる人たくさんありました
自分もそれを目指しているんですけどなかなか
そういうことができないです
これも授業で a
震災の時でも自分の人生のだけの重要と思うんですけどまず何をするか決めれば
それと
飽きられないでずっとする過程でやっていくと
必要なものとしその人が集めてきて
で実現することができます
私とよく言われるんですけど
最初はに負けかなぁという様と思ったんですけど気付いがとうございます
ウィンナーが何もできないから登録いただいたかと言うんですけど動くことは子はへ
ん
でこういうものは
最初の1本だけ公園ですよ
振り入れから怖いものはないんです
これも911の時によくのところでもなりました
震災なぁとみんなが優しくなるん
なぜかポイントスペースがあって
共通感じて自分はちょっとは神育っ
こういうところで癒したいから人と接する事がしたくなるからみんな挨拶するように
なる
人としつつあるところまいります
これは震災なくてもできるでしょ
笑い方あ
hey
名義が高めるという表明すると思うんですけど
石井笑うと
人間と親密関係が高まる
もう人間当院への間の関係がなくなります
それで直行試してみましょう今自分の境地を
考えてください
この次の s を見てからというの気持ちという宮中3画
のっ黒子
みんなで笑わなきゃダメあるバー本当にいいね名機力高めなきゃダメよ
あっはぁ
犬ずっ
あっほちゃございんどうぞパーカーだパッヘルベル
あっはぁ
あっは笑いは
パワーだねハッハー
ああああああああああああ
あっはっはあれはライナー歳と言われたんですかっ
はーはっはっは
と一気になんじゃねあああああ
カラーあーはっはっは
ねえ ini
じゃないもっと貼れない僕らあればスペインがダメだったんだよ
ブーバーし
てないんだってくれ込んだ3部マフィア檻さあ
はっはー4イェイイェイ iaea
はあああああ
4 r に
前にしてねんワッハ
友人を払うと
気付きが得ますよ
もういいから正しい上の観点を追われたらもらってどうもぐらすんなって
笑って力つけて良い超えることです
最後にまず作用じゃないんですけど
あっているございましたーーー
自分の人生なかも
震災がなくても繋げなくなってもこの夏の知恵を身につけることができると思います
まずは
1たまるため頑張る
素晴らしい一になって
医大の人生をこい
もう一つは
地図が
形にしたよう
ねぇ
それで送迎会恐怖を乗り越えて
自分の理想を
実現する
そして
我ながら
5倍の人のとの間の壁をなくして地獄金融機を強くしてください
非常移住
最後にあのー
石巻のお母さん歌歌えないです
僕はさん
嶋千保母さんといいですね
すごいたですね
福原さんが合格
あのー凄さあっ
俺たち様がそれがいで下さいと言っ
をずーっと後はなく言ったんです
それですぐワークさんの歌を作ります
ぶーああはの
魚梅まん
皮膚ずくめ muse かー
星座ん2
道具えーい
とうって言ってい
あーんよ集このことは忘れないで
えええかなパターは忘れない
トークン笑いに来てください
話せますか